so i want to talk about seven
uh because seven's a bit of a weird
number i mean it's weird because it's
hard to work out when something is
divisible by seven if you've ever tried
to do that you got oh is that seven
times table ah so i wanted to show you
one weird trick uh to work out if
something's divisible by seven you do
need to know your seven times table a
little bit up to like say a hundred but
then if you have a larger number this is
a useful trick so we'll pick a number
four hundred 434
is it divisible by seven i don't know
just looking at it i can't tell so this
is my one weird trick you split it up
into two parts i'm going to remove the
last digit and we've got the rest of it
as 43 and the last digit has four and
the trick is this five
times the last digit so it's gonna be
five times four plus the rest
forty-three that's the little
calculation i'm gonna do what have i got
i've got twenty
plus 43
is equal to 63. if that answer is
divisible by seven your number was
divisible by seven and it is that is
what nine times seven so i now know
434 is divisible by seven that's the
little trick it works the other way as
well if that had failed the test if it
was not a multiple of seven then the
original number is not a multiple of
seven either and you can even do this
repeatedly if you've got a really big
number you can actually do this a couple
of times let's say you got a bigger
number 6468
is that divisible by seven i don't know
i'm going to use my trick so what i can
do is i take the last digit eight go
multiply that by five and i add on the
rest
646. what i got here 40 plus 646
686 still don't know if that's divisible
by seven but i can repeat the process so
i'll just go again take the last digit
so six times five and add the rest the
68. well if i got 30 plus 68 it's 98 do
you know what i could stop there i know
98 is divisible by seven
but just for fun let's take it one extra
step further maybe you don't know 98 is
divisible by seven last digit is eight
times five plus the rest which would
just be a 9 and that would be 40 plus 9
is 49. yeah i'm confident that's
divisible by 7. it's 7 squared and
therefore my original number which was
the big number the 6468.
it's a multiple of 7. what do you do if
you do the process to 49
oh okay okay let's find out i don't know
i haven't done it let's find out 49
uh okay last digit is a nine
times five
plus the rest of it which is just the
four and now what i'm gonna get here
here nine times five
is forty-five tell me if i'm wrong hmm i
forgot that uh plus four oh it's 49. all
right oh dear we've got ourselves into a
loop
these numbers can get larger because i'm
adding
with this test i'm adding a number on
like so they kind of get big um there is
an alternative version we could do which
might be more useful because the numbers
get smaller instead i do split it up
again there's the 43 and the four i take
the rest as i was calling it the 43 i
subtract two times the last digit this
time so this time it would be 43 minus 8
which would be 35 is that divisible by 7
yes it is therefore my number was
so that's a subtracting version of it
which might be more useful in some
situations maybe less useful in other
situations
do you want to hear why it's true you
might want to try and work out why it's
true actually um but i am going to show
you so if you want to work it out
make sure you do that i'm going to show
you how it works why is that true so if
i write a number i could write a number
like this as 10x plus y y is the last
digit and this 10x is the rest or the x
is what i was calling the rest that's
just a different way of writing down a
number so i want to know if this is
divisible by 7. i hope you would agree
that if if this is divisible by 7
5 times the number is divisible by 7 as
well i think that's true isn't it yeah
so let's multiply this by 5. so i'm
going to multiply this by 5 so what am i
going to get 50x plus 5y so i might want
to know is that divisible by 7 i'm going
to split this up in a different way i'm
going to have a little bracket here i'm
going to have x plus 5y in a bracket and
what's left over i guess it's all the
x's i haven't used this 49x left over
so i want to know is this divisible by
seven
49 x's definitely i know that's
definitely divisible by seven so really
the only thing
that i need to ask is is that bracket
is divisible by seven but that bracket
is my test
this is my five times the last digit
plus the rest so if that bracket
passes the test if it's divisible by
seven the original number was divisible
by seven and if it's not then the
original number wasn't either is it ever
important to know if a number is
divisible by seven
i i'm sure i can think of situations
where you would need to find if
something is divisible by seven i mean
it's more useful to know when things are
difficult by um four
or two
or six is kind of useful and seven is
less useful unless you go into like a
restaurant and you've got
seven people and you want to split the
bill you know that kind of thing so i
can imagine rugby maybe converted tries
in rugby or or a touchdown with a field
goal with the conversion a touchdown
with a conversion seven points yeah look
at my face look how blank my face is now
i have no idea what you're talking about
but maths is good isn't it
now that we've seen a test for the
divisibility of seven maybe it's nice to
do a recap of some of the tests for
smaller numbers and they might be useful
keep them in your pocket and then you'll
know them
right how to tell if your number is
divisible seven we know we've now got a
test for this and it was the five times
last digit plus rest awesome tick one
well everything's divisible by one okay
i'll just write that in the everything
let's do the easy ones next um
divisible by two
even right even numbers but another way
of saying
even is they end
with a zero a two a four or an eight
and then you know it's six oh all right
and five is an easy one as well isn't it
uh ends with a zero or five yep and
ten's an easy one ends with a zero cool
those are the easy ones the next easiest
test i think it's divisible by nine i've
actually done a video about divisible by
nine a trick that can check your
arithmetic
but i think this is something that
everyone should know before we called it
casting out nines or the rule of nine
and the test for this is something
called the digit sum we add up all the
digits and if the digit sum is divisible
by nine tick the original number was
let's just do an example i'll steal the
example i did before right six thousand
four hundred and sixty eight so the
digit sum would be adding up the digits
six plus four plus six plus eight what
have i got there uh 10 16 24 which i
guess means it's not divisible by nine
that failed the divisibility test
but it does pass the test for three the
test for three is the digit sum again
this time if the digit sum is divisible
by three the original number was
divisible by three eleven shall we have
a look at the test for eleven that's the
alternating sum it's the same idea
really you alternate the plus and
minuses let's do that example to show
you what i mean
uh so i had this number again the the
six thousand four hundred and sixty
eight start with the six you subtract
the four you add the six you subtract an
eight so you keep plus and minusing the
digits like that if that's zero or a
multiple of eleven it passes the test
what if i got here it's a two and eight
minus an eight is a zero that's okay so
if it's a zero it passes the test that
means it's a multiple of 11. my number
was a multiple of 11. all right so what
have we got left
the next easiest one is six
how do we know if it's divisible by six
well all you do is you apply two tests
does it pass divisibility by two and
the visibility by three
if it does
then it's divisible by six so you have
to pass two tests divisibility by
two and three what about my example i've
been using the 6468
yeah many it passed the three test and
it passes the even test
so it's divisible by six
uh you do the 12 the same way so it just
needs to pass divisibility by three and
four or i haven't done four so i should
mention it
four
what is the divisibility by four test
you look at the last two digits i messed
up that's used by example here i just
care about the 68.
i really don't care how big this number
is either it's just it's just the 68 i
care about and then is that divisible by
four you might think but is that hard
working out that's divisible by four and
i like to do um can i divide by 2 twice
is it doubly even so is it can i divide
by 2 and then is that even i can divide
by 2 again so if i did that
68 is it doubly even it'd be 34
and then yeah that's even which would be
a 17 if i halved it again that passes
and for eight
this is the apart from seven i say eight
is that maybe the harder one it's the
last three digits
don't care how big the number is but
it's the last three
digits
and
i'll do my little example here's my 6468
i only care about the end of it the 468
part there it is
is that divisible by eight that's again
kind of hard is it triply even
then so is it even can i divide by two
can i divide by two can i divide by two
so a little harder but i think you could
do that in your head let's try it 468
234 for halving it and then can i halve
it again 117
so i've halved it once i've halved it
twice i think i'm gonna get stuck so
it's not divisible by eight because it
wasn't triply even
this video was supported by jane street
a research driven trading firm based out
of all the great cities like new york
hong kong
and london
now they're supporting us because some
of the people at jane street enjoy
watching number five but they also think
the sort of people watching like you are
the curious and creative types that
might be a good fit to work with them
one of the great ways you can do that is
through their internship program
and the next round of those are actually
being advertised as we speak
there's a link on the screen but i'll
also put all the stuff you need in the
video description so you can check it
out have a look people this could be the
first step for you to an amazing and
exciting international career
and our thanks to the people at jane
street for supporting numberphile
[Music]
the visibility
i thought it would just be nice to do a
recap of um divisibly
say that again i thought it'd just be
nice to do a recap of disability oh
oh this is turning into good bonus
material
i've discovered a word i can't say